[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any of you
out there would like to ask
questions--
PENG YING: Hey, and welcome to
another episode of Google
Payments Live.
My name is Peng Ying.
Unfortunately, Mihai can't
be with us today.
He's in Hawaii.
Tough life, right?
And joining me today
is Mark Thomas.
Mark, tell us a little
bit about yourself.
MARK THOMAS: Hi, Peng.
Hi, everyone out there.
So my name is Mark, and I've
been a PM at Google for about
two years, and I'm a Product
Manager on Google Wallet.
PENG YING: Cool.
So tell us a little
bit more about the
product that you manage.
MARK THOMAS: Sure.
So right now, I'm working
on a project
called Commerce Analytics.
So what we're trying to do is
build a suite of tools that
help people that use Google to
sell, like app developers, web
and app developers, to better
understand their business.
So by focusing on analyzing
purchase data, basically your
sales data, we want to help make
it more obvious how to
make more money, how to improve
your products, and how
to get more customers.
PENG YING: So, I mean,
I've used Google
Analytics a little bit.
Can you tell me how Commerce
Analytics is going to be
different from Google
Analytics?
MARK THOMAS: Sure,
good question.
So Commerce Analytics is really
focusing on your sales
data and analyzing
your sales data.
Google Analytics provides
metrics around bounce rates
and page views.
We are really, again, focusing
just on the purchase events,
so Commerce Analytics is a good
complement for Google
Analytics in that regard.
Some other interesting things,
Commerce Analytics requires no
instrumentation to get
up and running.
So as soon as you start selling,
you will start
getting Commerce Analytics, and
I think that's a really
exciting thing.
We also provide demographic
charts and demographic
analyses of your customers,
which is something that is not
yet available in Google
Analytics.
PENG YING: So are there
any other synergies?
Like what else can I get
if I leverage both?
Is there any additional
insight?
MARK THOMAS: Yes, you should
definitely leverage both.
I think Google Analytics, again,
provides a lot of great
tools for tracking many events
and engagement metrics.
So again, page views, bounce
rates, conversion rates,
things like that, and they can
also help you track your apps
and your products across
the platforms.
So if you develop for multiple
platforms, Google Analytics is
a great tool for that.
Commerce Analytics is a great
"out the box," "get up and
running quick with no
effort" tool to
use for a quick analysis.
And we may also be providing
some deeper dives into how to
better analyze and better think
about your sales data in
particular.
PENG YING: So you kind of went
over this a little bit in the
description, but what are
we hoping to provide to
developers/ and then how should
they use it, a little
bit, for Commerce Analytics?
MARK THOMAS: I take that to mean
so what is the ultimate
vision for Commerce Analytics?
PENG YING: Yeah.
MARK THOMAS: Yeah, and I think
that's a great question.
So in our UX studies, we
heard a really great
quote from a developer.
He was saying the hardest part
about analytics in general is
actually defining the right
questions to ask.
And that's the ultimate problem
we want to solve.
The truth of matter is not
everyone can afford hiring an
analyst to look and crunch
numbers as a full-time job.
And even if you can, sometimes
there are things you miss.
Well, Google is really good at
diving into the data, digging
through it and finding
useful information.
So let us do that, and let
us tell you when we find
something that's interesting.
So I think it's an ambitious
vision, but I think it's where
we're headed.
PENG YING: Cool.
I mean, you must have dug into
a lot of data while you're
developing this product.
Do you have any interesting
stories or
anything that you found?
MARK THOMAS: Yeah.
As we were looking into this,
one thing that really leaped
out at me was just how useful
just looking and analyzing
sales data can really be.
So another great quote from a
developer that we got in our
studies, with something like
this, they said, you can look
at daily active users.
You can look at these metrics.
But ultimately at the end of the
day, it's really about are
people buying things and are
people spending money?
I mean, if you're a business
that cares about being
profitable, the ground truth
for you is did somebody buy
something from me?
Who are my best customers?
How can I get more of them?
And that's where Commerce
Analytics, I think,
can really help out.
And looking at page views and
daily actives, again, pretty
standard, but it's harder to
quantify what the value is of
those things, especially
if you're
selling goods and services.
PENG YING: So why don't we just
dive into the product
right now and check out what
you've got to offer?
MARK THOMAS: Yeah,
I would love to.
All right.
So this is the beta version
of Commerce Analytics.
It is available today for a
select subset of test users
right now, and you can find
it in your Google Checkout
Merchant Center.
When it becomes available,
you'll see it under this
Business Insights tab.
So, we provide a few
standard charts.
The first, you'll notice we've
got a revenue chart which is
just showing you amount
of revenue over time.
So that's a landing page, and
this is useful for trying to
see some things like are
my sales seasonal?
Was there a particular
spike or a drop?
Was that expected?
And if so, you can dive
into that analysis.
PENG YING: This guy's
sales were spiky.
MARK THOMAS: Yes.
This is for our test merchant,
so you can see here that it
looks like August 31 was the
biggest day thus far for our
little test merchant.
So we also provide a Map View
so you can see a geographic
heat map of where your
purchasers are coming from.
So here, a lot of them coming
from the United States, but we
can see that there are also,
on a revenue basis, some
activity, a decent amount of
activity, in Europe, Southeast
Asia, and even Latin America.
PENG YING: We have testers
everywhere.
MARK THOMAS: Indeed.
Indeed we do.
So we also provide an orders
charts, and orders is a good
measure of popularity.
How popular are your products?
How popular are certain
products?
And generally, this should
correlate closely to revenue,
but if you're running a
promotion, like a $0.10 app
promotion or something, you
may see a large spike in
orders, and you wouldn't see as
big of a spike in revenue.
And so I think this is a good
time to point out that we have
a couple of filters over
here on the side.
You can filter by country.
You can filter by product.
So you can really start diving
into the data here and try to
get a more specific view into
how particular products are
doing over time.
PENG YING: Refunds.
That's a section that
nobody wants to see.
MARK THOMAS: Indeed, indeed.
PENG YING: Or maybe that
everybody wants to see.
It's like probably the
most important.
MARK THOMAS: Yeah, refunds, the
goal here was to try to
provide some insight into is
something going wrong or where
am I making sales initially
that end up not being
successful?
So we show refunds over time and
also by geography, but you
could use this to really try
to get a sense for are we
getting more refunds from
certain parts of the real
world than others?
Are certain products being
refunded more than others?
And if so, you can start to dive
into why that might be.
And for example, you may not
want to spend as much ad
revenue if you find that there
are countries with large
number of refunds for
particular products.
OK, so now I'll switch over
to the customer's view.
So this is where we're
starting provide some
demographic data, and the goal
here is to really provide some
tools to help you segment
your customers.
We want to help you answer
the question
who are my best customers?
So this is an early stab
at doing that.
But what we provide today is
a breakdown of revenue and
orders by age range
and gender.
And this is being pulled from
a combination of explicitly
provided and inferred
demographic data, and it's
aggregated up here so as to
preserve the privacy of your
customers, of course.
So you can see here that the
products here, the age range
tends to be between 18 and 24
when broken down by revenue.
Also by revenue, we can see
that the males hold the
majority of buying power for
this particular test merchant.
And again, we also break it
down by order volume.
So again, revenue and order
should be generally
well-correlated, but you may
have promotions, you may have
certain products where they
are very popular with a
certain demographic category.
PENG YING: A large percentage of
males guzzling electronics
right here.
MARK THOMAS: Electronics yes.
Mostly games, here.
So one other chart I want to
point out is the unique
buyer's chart.
And so, this is just trying to
give you an idea for how many
unique people made a purchase
on a given day, so each day
has the total number
of unique buyers.
And this should give you an
idea for how many people
you're actually reaching.
It also starts to give you a
sense for am I reaching a
small number of very
loyal customers?
That is, do I have one
unique buyer, but
1,000 orders in a day?
So do I have one person that's
buying 1,000 things, or do I
have 1,000 people buying
one thing?
And so, that can help you inform
how you want to target
your products.
Do you want to really go after
your rock star users, or is
this more of a product that
has a broader appeal?
PENG YING: So now that you've
gone through some the
functionality of it, as a
developer, I'm selling a bunch
of apps, right?
Or I'm selling one
app or whatever.
How should I then come into
the business insights and
leverage it?
Can you go through some of the
flows that you typically see?
MARK THOMAS: Sure.
So the first thing you need to
do, I think, as any sort of
business analyst, you need to
come into the product having
done a little bit of homework.
And what that means is you
should know what to expect.
If you've launched a product,
you should know what day that
product launched, where that
launched, in which countries,
and whether or not you've done
any sort of promotion.
And you should also know what
sort of impact you expect to
have on sales, on orders,
on unique
buyers, things like that.
So know what to expect.
That's the first step.
And then once you get into the
insights, the business
insights tab and start looking
at your commerce analytics,
just start diving
into the data.
I would suggest aggressively
filtering.
Look at all the charts.
Test your expectations against
everything that we have.
So start looking at a
per-product revenue chart,
per-product orders chart, per
product, per country.
You'll never know where you'll
find that little nugget of
insight that can help you
boost your sales.
So know what to expect,
and then get down and
dirty with the data.
PENG YING: I'm not sure if you
know the answer to this
question, but now that I have
the business insights, now
that I have targeted a few
audiences, what can I do to
improve sales in those target
audiences, in the target
demographic?
MARK THOMAS: I see.
So this is where you can
start to look at--
hopefully, the insights that we
provide here might provide
you some suggestions.
So, for example, if I notice
that I have a large customer
base in a particular country,
but I haven't localized any of
the text, I've haven't
translated any of the text
into the local language, that
might be one way to increase
engagement rates.
So that's something
you could do.
Also, if you haven't been
running any app promotions,
you can start looking at, for
example, the customer
demographics data to try to
pull out some demographic
targeting information.
If you tend to reach 18 to
25-year-old males, then you
can start to input that into
some advertising tools to help
better target your app launches
and your apps.
PENG YING: I wasn't quite sure
about this, but can you filter
by specific items you're selling
to see demographic
data specific to the item?
MARK THOMAS: So for demographics
data, today we
are not actually providing that
filtering functionality.
We're working on it.
As you can imagine, there are a
lot of privacy concerns that
we take very, very seriously
here, so we want to make sure
that when we do provide
that sort of filtering
functionality here, that we can
do so in a way that's safe
for customers.
However, on the sales and
revenue and orders charts, we
do provide the ability to filter
down by country, and
again, by product.
And of course, time.
PENG YING: Super useful.
So this seems like something
that's very useful that comes
pretty much out of the box for
merchants and developers.
How would they access
it through their
own merchant accounts?
Is there any way to access it
or join the beta early?
MARK THOMAS: Yeah.
So let me present
the link here.
If you're interested, we have
a Google form which you can
reach at this shortened URL.
I encourage you to fill
out the form.
We can't guarantee that we'll be
able to bring you on to the
beta immediately, but the good
news is we're looking at
rolling this out much more
broadly in the coming months.
So very shortly, we expect
everyone who uses Google to
sell to have Commerce
Analytics.
Again, go to the form, fill it
out if you're interested.
We'd love to hear from you.
We also have a section on there
for additional comments.
So if you have any suggestions
for things you would like to
see, things that you would
find very useful, please,
please do let us know.
So yeah, looking forward to
having some more users and
some more feedback on this.
PENG YING: Cool.
I think it's really awesome.
I think it provides super easy
insight into what you're
selling and how you can
improve your sales.
And that's all the questions
I have for you.
Let's see if there are
any live questions.
MARK THOMAS: Sure.
PENG YING: I'm looking at
the Moderator right now.
So it doesn't look like these
questions are actually related
to Commerce Analytics.
"I am a Brazilian developer,
and nowadays payments in
Brazil are very complex.
Paypal is a more straightforward
way to pay.
How can Google fix
this problem?"
MARK THOMAS: It's
a big question.
PENG YING: Internationalization
has
always been a huge question with
Google Wallet, and we're
always trying to improve
the number of
countries that we support.
But in order for us to expand
into new countries, we always
have to go through the regular
rules and regulations and
follow proper paperwork, and
that's probably why it takes
some time to expand
internationally.
But we are trying to do it.
Let's see about the YouTube.
Just one second--
well, I have a few questions
for you.
A few more questions for
you if you don't mind.
MARK THOMAS: Lay it on me.
PENG YING: So are we doing
anything with Google Offers?
I know that as a merchant,
I can sell offers.
Will my offers be tracked within
Commerce Analytics?
Like really quickly figure out
who's buying from where, and
then maybe target those areas
with better offers, or like
more coupons, or ads,
or whatever?
MARK THOMAS: Yeah, absolutely.
I think the short answer is
we're looking into it, and the
general sentiment, though, is
that anyone that uses Google
to sell should be able to
have Commerce Analytics.
And in general, anyone who sells
something could benefit
from a tool like this.
That's sort of the way that
we feel on the team.
So I'll sort of leave
it there, but
very interesting stuff.
PENG YING: We have one
more question.
So I hear this is what Amazon
does, because they have a
sense of the entire
marketplace.
And I'm not actually sure.
I haven't been in Amazon
market, but this is
just word of mouth.
But I hear what they do is,
because they have an entire
sense of who's selling what
and how often and the
frequency of it, they can
actually say that these items
will be your top sellers.
Nobody else is selling this
item, so you should increase
the price, and other
stuff like that.
Is that an area that we
want to get into?
Or can you not talk about--
MARK THOMAS: I will say that
there's a lot of very
interesting things
that we can do.
There's a lot of very
interesting things that we can
do, so stay tuned.
PENG YING: Stay tuned.
Join the beta, or sign
up for the beta.
And eventually, can you get into
when we expect to have
open access for this, or this
is still a work in progress?
MARK THOMAS: So the exact
date is to be
determined, but we will--
well, I shouldn't say that.
It's coming in the next, I
would say, two months.
PENG YING: Nice.
Very soon.
Cool.
Looking forward to it.
And with that, I think that's
all the questions we
have for you today.
No more of this interrogation.
MARK THOMAS: Thanks.
Thanks for having me.
PENG YING: Well, thanks
for joining.
And we'll have another Google
Payments Live in two weeks.